kiev sigue pidiendo ayuda y europa
responderá en la conferencia
internacional de donantes de varsovia el
jueves el presidente ucraniano volodymyr
selenski hizo una aparición virtual
pidiendo más asistencia económica 2 está
en finanzas de recursos necesitamos
suficientes recursos económicos para que
los hombres y las mujeres de ucrania
puedan estar provistos de los
suficientes recursos que necesiten
mientras la guerra continúa el estado
ucraniano como administrador de estos
cubrirá todas las necesidades urgentes
en defensa y ayuda humanitaria y
humanitaria por el momento ya han
surgido resultados inmediatos del
proceso elogiado por los líderes
europeos
en esta conferencia fuimos capaces de
reunir más de 6 mil millones de euros y
este dinero será distribuido para apoyar
a ucrania y todos aquellos que apoyan a
ucrania porque sabemos cuán doloroso y
costoso está siendo para la nación
ucraniana ruina
it's for you crying in nation entre los
países que aumentaron su asistencia se
incluyen finlandia república checa
croacia
quien amplió su ayuda anual a ucrania en
300 millones de euros para el presidente
del consejo europeo charles michel
podría ser la plataforma de lanzamiento
para una futura recuperación completa
queremos de estar operativos y este
encuentro y la decisión que salga hoy en
mi opinión debe ser un punto de partida
para un plan marshall europeo para
ucrania
esto significa que ayudará a ucrania y
ayudaremos a la gente de ucrania
el encuentro llega cuando zelinski
intenta ganar tiempo en la esfera global
para facilitar la asistencia financiera
el jueves su gobierno también lanzó una
plataforma de crowdfunding global
llamada united twenty ford todas las
donaciones serán transferidas al banco
de ucrania y asignadas a los ministerios
más importantes del país